qu'est-ce que vous feriez si votre
voisin laissait son boyau d'arrosage et
inondé votre terrain puis votre sous-sol
par négligence vous lui demanderiez vous
dédommagez pour les dégâts c'est
exactement ce que les pays en
développement exigent de la communauté
internationale quand il est question des
pertes et dommages une expression qui
revient année après année avec toujours
un peu plus d'insistance à chaque
nouvelle conférence des parties sur les
changements climatiques c'est un petit
marteau
on les appelle aussi les pertes et
préjudices ce sont des dégâts causés par
un climat qui se réchauffe mais contre
lesquels les mesures d'adaptation ne
suffisent pas on assiste à la
salinisation par exemple de certaines
terres agricoles des populations perdent
leur village parce qu'ils ne sont plus à
même de faire de l'agriculture à cause
des sécheresses les pertes dommages
touchent aussi les écosystèmes et la
biodiversité comme quand une espèce
disparaît à cause des dérèglements
climatiques mais malheureusement les
pertes se calculent souvent en vie
humaine des peuples entiers et leurs
cultures sont menacées disparaître
les petits États insulaires ceux qui
sont situés près du niveau de la mer
demande depuis 1991 qu'un système de
compensation financière soit mis en
place mais depuis 189 millions de
personnes par année sont touchées par
des catastrophes climatiques dans les
pays en développement si bien que depuis
30 ans une centaine de pays
principalement du Sud ont joué leur voix
à celle des insulaires des pays qui
historiquement n'ont pratiquement pas
contribué au changement climatique et
c'est ICI que ça se complique parce que
les pays développés qui ont le plus émis
de gaz à effet de serre sont réticents à
reconnaître pleinement leur
responsabilité historique et la facture
serait salée elle se situerait entre 300
à 600 milliards de dollars par année
jusqu'en 2030 et encore plus ensuite
jusqu'en 2050 en 2021 à la cop26 à
Glasgow la proposition de créer un
mécanisme de financement dédié aux
pertes à la toute dernière minute par la
création d'un groupe de discussion si
encore une fois les pays
font encore l'autruche et accepte d'en
parler mais tant que ça ne les implique
pas activement je pense que ça ça va
générer des insatisfactions très grandes
de la part des pays les plus vulnérables
qui eux subissent d'un premier chef les
impacts d'une crise qu'ils ont
certainement pas créé comme perte et
préjudice et droits humains sont
indissociables certains souhaitent que
la justice intervienne et ont même déjà
commencé à s'adresser au tribunaux
internationaux le sujet est plus brûlant
que jamais plusieurs garde espoirs que
durant la cop27 les négociations
débouchent sur un vrai système financier
qui épongera les pertes et dommages